[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué hago
estudió ingeniería en petróleo que todo
el mundo me dice que tiene buena
inserción laboral o me juego por
fotografía que es lo que yo amo
yo quiero estudiar enfermería pero mis
padres me torturan y todo el tiempo me
dicen estudia medicina estudia medicina
es más sólida es más importante yo no
quiero estudiar medicina pero tampoco lo
quiero defraudar
qué hago le digo lo que siento o mejor
me lo guardo estoy podrido de la oficina
harto lo único que quiero es renunciar
ya
pero mejor me quedo un tiempo más y pago
todas mis deudas
todo el tiempo estamos eligiendo
de hecho numerosos autores a lo largo de
la historia han dicho que la vida es la
suma de nuestras elecciones y según mi
opinión
ante cada situación aunque más aunque
pastor durante difícil la sintamos
siempre tenemos ese margen de libertad
para poder decidir qué actitud tomar
frente a ellas
como eligen ustedes
priorizan su razón su intuición su
corazón son más bien impulsivos o
reflexivos tienden a arrepentirse más de
lo que no se animan a hacer o de lo que
sí hicieron
se torturan analizando cada alternativa
se dejan llevar por lo que otros les
dicen
el mundo de las elecciones siempre me
fascinó
y una de mis pasiones es la orientación
vocacional y acompañar a jóvenes y
también adultos a descubrir su potencial
enorme
y a tratar de detectar cuáles son
aquellas carreras o trabajos más
vinculados con sus intereses o más
alineados con las metas que quieren
alcanzar como entonces tomar decisiones
mejor fundamentadas y más alineadas con
lo que yo soy quiero y pienso según mi
experiencia profesional teniendo en
cuenta dos grandes aspectos el mundo
externo
y contexto y mi mundo interno
conociéndome a mí mismo
suena tan aburrido no es tan fascinante
vamos al mundo externo que carreras que
cursos que oficios existen a qué se
dedica cada uno de ellos en la práctica
qué percepción tenemos y qué
posibilidades de proyección hacia futuro
tiene cada una de ellas sabían que hay
un cálculo varios en realidad que
estiman que dentro de 15 a 25 años gran
parte de las carreras y trabajos que
existen hoy en la manera en que existen
no van a estar más y que muchos de los
que están en estos momentos dentro de
unas décadas van a ser reemplazados por
robots con inteligencia artificial
entonces qué hacemos frente a esto les
esperamos nos deprimimos no hacemos nada
déjenme hacerles una sugerencia no se
queden con una sola opción porque todos
tenemos gustos e intereses por mucho más
de una cosa y por lo tanto por mucho más
de una carrera ocupación oficio trabajo
algunos hemos aprendido que teníamos que
elegir una sola cosa para toda la vida y
si bien en algunos casos esto funciona
de acuerdo a la realidad todos cambiamos
lo externo cambio
y la decisión que yo tome en un momento
de mi vida no necesariamente tiene que
ser afín coherente con mis necesidades y
mis posibilidades actuales
para los que tengan el privilegio de
estudiar porque no todo el mundo puede
hacerlo me animo a hacerles una
sugerencia
no elijan de acuerdo a lo que se os
llamó menú de restaurante qué quiere
decir mirando el lado de los precios
dicen maravilloso dos años no quería
estudiar más que eso me anoté o del otro
lado del menú no tiene ni una sola
materia de matemática qué suerte porque
yo no lo soportaba más me anoto ahí
y que se olvidan que a lo largo de los
dos primeros años van a tener materias
generales introductorias básicas
aburridas teóricas abstractas
que muchas de esas materias le van a
gustar y otras no y algunas le van a
resultar fáciles y otras difíciles
entonces sugerencia pongan el foco un
poco más allá en que van a estar
haciendo parte del día semanas meses a
veces años pero no toda mi vida
algo más importante acá
quiero detenerme si me permiten en mi
mundo interno
como descubrir mi potencial
conociéndome a mí mismo
recuerden estas preguntas como soy
que quiero que me gusta que me resulta
fácil que quiero hacer algo que me guste
que me apasione porque si no pierdo
rápidamente el interés y la motivación y
abandono lo que estoy haciendo tener
poder político reconocimiento tiempo
libre para dedicar a mis afectos a mis
hobbies todas las opciones son válidas y
cada una de las decisiones que tomamos y
que no tomamos tienen consecuencias
que me resulta fácil lo científico lo
exacto filmar actuar escribir
como soy extrovertido sensible
introvertido familiar o
que me gusta
y ahora vamos a ir a tratar de seguir
algunas pistas que como detectives
privados de nosotros mismos podemos ir
sacando a la luz
en qué tipo de lugares o ámbitos me
gusta y disfruto estar al aire libre en
lugares cerrados concurridos solitarios
oficinas institutos de investigación
haciendo que investigando asesorando
ayudando
llevando la contabilidad
con qué o con quién buena parte del
tiempo personas de qué edad es
sustancias químicas elementos de
laboratorio dibujo diseño cuadros
gráficos
hay algo importante acá pero primero
vamos a un ejemplo concreto me gusta
conocer lugares y viajar me resultan muy
fáciles los idiomas
soy práctica y concreta listo azafata
pero a mí también me resulta fundamental
estar con mis hijos todas las mañanas y
llevarlos a la escuela
ese estilo de vida
no va a conducir con el estilo de
trabajo que tiene esa ocupación o
profesión y ahí viene de vuelta la
sugerencia de que busquen muchas
opciones porque además tienen un
potencial infinito que ir descubriendo
en estos años
les cuento que cuando voy contando a las
personas después de hacer muchos tests y
muchas tareas y muchos cuestionarios las
últimas carreras entre las cuales las
personas en general están dudando
ay ante alguna que le brillan los ojos
si ustedes tienen hijos sobrinos amigos
traten de detectar ese brillo especial
porque ese brillo muestra algo que está
adentro y que la razón no puede llegar a
profundizar
abran esa puerta adentro nuestro sabemos
realmente lo que queremos y sentimos
algo más para tomar decisiones mejor
fundamentadas pedir y recibir ayuda
hace un tiempo ante una decisión difícil
que yo estaba tomando en mi vida uno de
mis hijos la mis amores me recordó una
pregunta que yo suelo hacer con mucha
frecuencia en las charlas en los cursos
y que en ese momento había olvidado por
completo me dijo mamá esta decisión
te acerca o te aleja de la persona que
quieres ser
jugarme por lo que quiero
o elegir llegar a fin de mes para pagar
las cuentas para mis hijos me acerca o
me aleja de sentirme más en paz y estar
más conforme conmigo misma
entonces escucho otros puntos de vista
me abro a otros criterios y vuelvo a mí
porque tengo una vida entre mis manos la
mía
que elijo hacer con ella del tierra la
ocultó la tapo de nuevo chiquitita por
miedo echo la culpa a este país al mundo
a mis padres a mi pareja a mi expareja
por todo lo que no pude y no me dejaron
hacer o pongo el foco en lo que sí soy
quiero y puedo
que el hijo
y tomar la arcilla que tengo entre mis
manos y construir algo único que nadie
más que yo
podrá modelar
crear
disfrutar y compartir con los demás
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]